so there's a video music video ah and
then if you guys know this girl she's
the cash cow side girl well first of all
she's one of the biggest rappers in the
world now one the biggest YouTube stars
and our boy he'll bonds in her new music
video bye bye he's on a and it's been
out for all I don't know has 7 million
views for days it is I've seen it battle
game Theo told me he was doing it dude
so I can hear Brendan and Brian are
watching the bad baby video I was in
with B head baby that's her yeah she's a
little kid she's forced his very own
channel they're judging me that's Joey
again Joe thank you and I'm not in there
with him they don't know that I'm here
I'm in my studio minerals do TLC a
bikini fight clean oh my god I can hear
him to the wall hey did they have casted
anymore had a foul side Petrucci so I'm
gonna see what they say his face
everyone everything weeks and how to
play a pervert in the video a registered
pervert it's a video about being
catfished I'm so into this right now
no this ty dolla sign yeah it was also
very huge very famous some curious as to
how they're gonna judge me for sure yeah
100%
please tell me Theo tonin killer no a
lot of dark movie there's honestly
nothing sadder than listening to two
other adult men watch you play a pervert
in a child's video warning people about
perverts she's drugging him she's
drugging up sterling this is serious
[ __ ]
it's alright it's just like a she's just
so famous that he gets so many views I
bet Callens gonna have some thoughts
because he's a registered actor Brendan
is just a wrestler basically that and
now he's like a um kind of like a
Instagram model pedo oh and she's gonna
brand him right about down somebody doe
our heads forehead oh wow wow that's
dope so he plays a pedophile big sense
I've ever seen what but did you know so
that girl got really famous cuz she was
on was it Maury dr. Phil dr. Phil and do
you have that original clip I can't let
me show you why this girl is this famous
she is Brian and it's gonna make you
sick
cuz it's the age we're living in now
with Instagram and you know and YouTube
stars and stuff like that 14 years old I
know I don't
she might be 17 or 18 she's not 17 or 18
but she did this okay this is a video
against pervert call him perverts town
don't fit into the video so this
launched her into being a mall type
she's richer than business she is a hood
red and she is out of control
hey also wait what how long you been
industry 20 years 20 years five it all
pretty cool more famous more famous hit
it hit it Jim this is why Brian she's
saying that he's more famous than Brian
she's only been in the industry for
[ __ ] two years do you know him
yeah it was the last time you saw what
have you so anyway that's what happens
here sometimes when this wall-to-wall
baby
welcome to wall-to-wall I'm Theo von now
today Brendan Schaub and Brian Collins
are in their studio of the fighter and
the kids and you've heard of their
podcast it's uh it's about two adults
that are basically struggling through
their early 40s and mid to late 50s in
the in Los Angeles and experienced in
life at a fast pace and also one of them
is taken and I'm shouldn't be saying
this because I love them but it's taking
remedial reading courses online but in
wall to wall it is basically where I sit
and they don't know that I'm
eavesdropping on them now today because
they're right behind this wall see this
is my studio right here that's not me
also people that is that's [ __ ] Chris
Farley okay just cuz I have a big nose
and he has a big nose doesn't mean
anything but this is their old studio
and through this wall right now they you
know I recently did a bad baby video
with be had baby and um I don't know
what she's anyway they're doing an
episode of fire in the kid in there
talking about how I was in the video and
I just happened to be in my studio and I
heard them talking about me and so of
course I'm going to listen dude put my
[ __ ] sound sucker out there and see
what I can catch and so that's what's
going on here
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this because this is alarming